[Müzik]
Evet gördüğünüz gibi Yol uzun
şöyle tarif edebiliriz 5 kere milyarı
çarpınca kolayca hesaplıyoruz sanırım
yapabilirsiniz fakat hızlansak varır
mıyız derken Ben size söyleyeyim boşa
heveslenmeyelim En azından Biz nesil
görmeyecek hızlansak da varamayız şimdi
Stephen Hawking diyor ki yani evreni
kavuruyor olmak bize canlılar arasında
bir ayrıcalık tanıyor Dolayısıyla
yolculuğu uzaklardan yani evrenin
sınırlarından başlatıp çekirdeğe doğru
geleceğiz Çünkü Evren yaklaşık 14 milyar
yıldır yaşıyor fakat biz atomu şurada
henüz 110 yıl önce keşfettik fakat
bakıyoruz ki bulgular bize diyor ki; bu
atom büyük patlamadan yani evrenin
oluşurken saniyenin
yolculuğun neresindeyiz sınırları neden
zorlamak istiyoruz insanoğlu olarak
nasıl bir yolculuk yapıyoruz böyle bir
gezintiye çıkalım istiyorum Dolayısıyla
öğrendiğince gerçekten bazı bulgularımız
var Yani aşağı yukarı 13 14 milyar yıl
önce bir patlama ile oluştuğunu
biliyoruz fakat biz evrenin sadece yüzde
beşini algılıyoruz görüyoruz Çünkü
maddesel olarak görebildiğimiz
dokunabildiğimiz kısmı bu büyük bir
kısmı Yani yaklaşık %95'e karanlık madde
ve karanlık enerjiden oluşuyor artı
milyarlarca galaksiden
bahsediliyor ve biz evrenin neresindeyiz
dediğimiz zaman bizim galaksimiz yani
Samanyolu galaksisi bu 225 milyar
galaksiden sadece birisi ve eğer boyut
olarak bakacak olursak evrenin yaklaşık
100 milyonda biri
basamağında bir çapı var bir de tabii ki
yani buradaki 10 üzeri 24 kilometreyi
tarif ederken Biraz önce 5 tane milyarı
çarparsak varırız dedim ama hiç kimse
tabi Tüm ömrünü yolda geçirmek istemez
fakat villa giden bir uçağa bindiğimiz
zaman lütfen dikkat 100 milyon kere bir
milyar yıl sürüyor bu yolculuk Yani ben
evrenin öbürünü merak ettim dediğimiz
zaman Dolayısıyla hiçbir zaman
fiziksel olarak Bizler İnsanoğlu oraya
gidemeyecek Tabii ki fakat onu algılama
gücüne sahibiz galaksimize geldiğimiz
zaman boyutlar belki Milyar kere milyar
kilometreye iniyor
galaksimizin de tabii ki sınırlarına Biz
fiziksel olarak ulaşamayız Üstelik
galaksimiz öyle bir Galaksi ki 200
milyon üzerinde gezegen var ve biz
dünyada yaşıyoruz Dünyamız o
Gezegenlerden sadece bir tanesi
fakat insanlık olarak evrenin
sınırlarını merak ederken bu sınırları
zorlarken Biz Tabii ki uzaklardan gelen
ışıkları sinyalleri yeni oluşmuş bir
takım yıldızları ya da çok önce oluşmuş
ama Işığı bize yeni ulaşan yıldızları
keşfederek onları kayıt altına alarak bu
keşifleri yapıyoruz biliyorsunuz Hubble
Teleskobu birçok veri ortaya koydu Ama
insanlık gerçekten evrenin oluşumunun
resmini çekebilir miyim diyerek Aralık
2021'de James web teleskobunu fırlattı
ve yaklaşık
570-541 kilometreye oturdu ancak
ilerleyen zaman içinde bir nokta 6
milyon km'ye yerleşecek ve görüyoruz ki;
13.5 milyar yılın öncesinin
resmini çeksin istiyoruz bu çok büyük
bir başarı olacak tabii ki ve 13.7
milyar yıldan bahsetmiştik biliyorsunuz
Demek ki James Evren oluştuktan sonraki
200 milyonuncu yıldan başlayarak ancak
evreni görüntüleyeceğiz Tabii ki bu bize
yetmeyecektir Tabii ki sınırları
zorlamaya devam edeceğiz ama ne ilginç
ki 14 milyonluk 14 milyar yıllık 14
milyar yaşındaki evrende Biz insanlık
olarak
adeta onun
milyarda birini Yani
pardon milyonda birini yani son 14000
yılı kayıt altına alabilmişiz yani Avcı
toplumdan tarım toplumuna 1800'lerin
sonundaki endüstri toplumundan 20
yüzyılın ikinci yarısından başlayarak
bilgi toplamına İçinde bulunduğumuz
yüzyılda da yani 21 yüzyılda da
ihtiyaçtan doğan bir süper akıllı toplum
yaklaşımıyla toplum 5-0'ı yakalıyoruz ya
da yakalamak istiyoruz Onun için bu son
14 bin yılı kayıt altına alabildiğimize
göre özellikle son yüzyıla bir değinmek
gerekir Çünkü
yeni yeni tamamladık sayılır birçok
ürününü kullanıyoruz uzunca ve önemli
bir yüzyılda İki Dünya Savaşı yaşandığı
kendi Cumhuriyetimizin de kurulduğu bir
Yüzyıl fakat yüzyılın sonunda Time
dergisinin yaptığı ankette görüyoruz ki
Einstein yüzyılın kişi seçildi ve tabii
çağı da atom çağı ismi verildi çok geniş
bir ankette oy kullandığım için
biliyorum
Einstein yüzyılın başında 1905'te
gerçekten
evrene ilişkin maddeye ilişkin
ışığa ilişkin özel görelilikle
fotoelektrik etki ile Kinetik Teori ile
ama belki de en önemlisi eştir MC
kareyle o kadar çok şey söyledi ki
bunların hepsi aynı ya da rastladı fakat
20'lerde Kuantum mekaniği ile birleşince
21'de biliyorsunuz kendisi Nobel ödülü
kazandı arkasından İkinci Dünya Savaşı
arkasından
radar lazer
elektronik ve bilgisayarla birleştiği
zaman biz iletişim dünyasında adeta
çığırlar yaşadık yani televizyon gibi
telefon gibi internet gibi
nükleer enerji gibi yani 20 yüzyıldan
kolayca hatırlayacağımız ve halen
kullanımımızda olan teknolojilere
kavuştuk Dolayısıyla
yani Çağın atom çağı olması onu şöyledir
belki yorumlamak lazım yani
20 yüzyılın ilk çeyreğinde
atomun içinden çıkan bilgiye yüzyılın
kalanında teknolojinin şekillenmesini
sağladı Bunu niye bu kadar vurgulamak
istedim Çünkü 21 yüzyılda yaşıyoruz
Hatta ilk şehrini tamamlamak üzereyiz
Biraz sonra bahsedeceğim sende atom
çekirdeğinden çıkardığımız bilgi de hiç
kuşkusuz 21 yüzyılın kalan döneminde
yani kalan 77 yılında diyelim
teknolojiye yön verecek
şimdi bu 20 yüzyılda başarılan en önemli
işlerden bir tanesi Tabii ki İkinci
Dünya savaşında
hasar görmüş adeta yıkılmış Avrupa'nın
bir araya gelerek atom fiziği
laboratuvarı kurma fikriydi ve bunu
1954'te hayata geçirdiler
bildiğimiz hepimizin bildiği Avrupa
ülkeler Araştırmalar Merkezi İsviçre
Fransa sınırında burada devasa
çarpıştırıcılar kuruldu Şimdi
çarpıştırıcı Derken Tabii ki elektron
Proton pozitron anti Proton gibi Temel
parçacıkları anlıyoruz fakat yerin 100
metre altında 27 kilometrelik tünelde
kurulan bu büyük hadron
çarpıştırıcısında Biz tüm temel
etkileşmeleri tüm Temel parçacıkları
sınıflandıran standart model diye
bildiğimiz modelde bilinmeyen bir tane
bozan kalmıştı onu aradık Esasen yani
kuruluş amaçlarından bir tanesi buydu
keşfimizi 2012'de yaptık Fakat bu keşif
o kadar çok şey söyledi ki bir tanesi
yani Özellikle x bozonu ya da tanrı
parçacı diyebiliyorsunuz anılıyor
peteriks ve arkadaşları 1964'te diyorlar
ki yani biz cisimlerin maddelerin yani
kütlesini nasıl kazandığını bilmiyoruz
ama bize göre bir alan olmalı bu alan
Bir Bozanlar oluşmalı ve bu alanla
etkileşenler kütle kazanmalı
etkileşmeyenler kazanmamalı şimdi bu
1964'te ortaya atılan hipotezin önerinin
2012'de bu büyük hadron çarpıştırısında
keşfedilmesi Esasen insanoğlunun son 500
yılda madde ile ilgili söyleyebildiği en
önemli sonuç oldu
yani birincisini biliyorsunuz Newton'un
elamcısı piyasası Bence bir teraziye
koyarsan madde miktarını ölçerim idi
1905'te Einstein dedi ki işte remcikere
Eğer bir cismi Işık hızına ulaştıracak
olursanız madde enerjiye dönüşebilir
Onun bu söylediğini Biz burada
hızlandırıcılarda enerjiyi parçacıklara
yani enerji maddeye dönüştürerek
kullanılmış oluyoruz ve en önemli
sonuçlardan bir tanesi evrene ilişkin bu
bilgi o kadar önemli ki dikkat ederseniz
işte Biz şu anda yaklaşık ne dedim 14
milyar yıl yaşıyoruz büyük patlamadan
sonra ama bakarsak ter elektron voltlar
yani Terra skill dediğimiz cern'de
ulaştığımız enerjilerle Big Bang yani
evrenin oluştuğu büyük Patlamaya 10
üzeri -10 saniye saniyenin 10 milyarda
biri kadar yaklaşmış durumdayız Bu ne
demek yani uzansam büyük patlamayı
yakacağım Ama maalesef öyle değil onun
için başlıktaki hızlansak varır mıyız
vurgusu buradan kaynaklanıyor Benim
çarpıştırıcıdaki kullandığım tamamını
kullanabildiğim enerjiyi aşağı yukarı 10
yılda bir 10 kat arttırıyorum Halbuki
Benim büyük Patlamaya varmam için
elimdeki enerjiyi bir milyon kat
artırmam gerekiyor Bu şu demek aşağı
yukarı yani 100.000 yıl sonra mı
ulaşacağız hocam denilebilir fakat sende
şu anda kurulumu başlayan 2040'lar gibi
çalışacak
dediğimiz yani Şimdiki 27 kilometrelik
çarpıştırıcının 100 km'lik olanını ve
toplam enerjinin de şimdikinin 100 katı
yani tere elektron volta 100 TL elektron
volta ulaştığını düşünürsek
belki 2040'lardan sonra toplayacağımız
veriler yani 2070'e kadar o verileri
analiz etmek istiyoruz Peki 30 yılda
değer verilerle destekledik diyelim 2100
civarında Gerçekten bu 100.000 yıllık
yolu sanki 100 yıla İndirebiliriz diye
fiziksel olarak beklentimiz var Gelinler
noktada doğadaki tüm etkileşme
kuvvetlerine anlamış durumdayız tüm
temel parçacıkların birbiriyle olan
ilişkilerini anlamış durumdayız fakat
tüm etkileşmeleri aynı bağlantıda
toplama Feza Gürsey hocamızın da katkıda
bulunduğu gibi büyük birleşik teoriyi
deniyesi olarak görmemiz O bahsettiğim
şimdiki enerjinin bir milyon katına
ulaşmamızı
gerektiriyor bu büyük Patlamaya 10 üzeri
eksi 10 saniye bizi yaklaştırdığı için
gerçekten
atom çekirdeğinden evrenin sınırlarına
derken atom çekirdeğinin detaylarında
evrenin oluşumunu anlamak Belki de
insanoğlunun en büyük başarısı bu
cern'de kurulan
çarpıştırıcıyı Uzaylılar gelip
incelediği zaman o kadar harika bir
makine ki o kadar uç değerlerdeki
parametreleri Uzaylılar gelip incelediği
zaman demişler ki bunu yapan
insanoğlundan korkulur Biz buradan
yavaştan gidelim diye böyle bir espriyle
anlatılıyor Tabii ki Nano dünyadan ve
mikro dünyadan bilgiye çıkarırken ışık
kaynaklarını kullanıyoruz Temel
parçacıkları kullanıyoruz
hızlandırıcıları kullanıyoruz dikkat
ederseniz hücreden DNA'ya atomdan
çekirdeğe çekirdeğin merkezinde Proton
protonun içindeki koyarlar onu seri -18
metreye inmiş yani ne derler metrenin
milyarda birinin milyarda biri benim o 5
tane milyarı çarparsak yolu hesaplarız
dediğimin 2 milyarı Esasen detayda yani
atom çekirdeğine inmek için
kullandığımız mesafe diğer 3 milyar ise
Dünyadan evrenin sınırlarına gitmek için
kullanmam gereken mesafe Tabii ki keşif
araçları olarak hızlandırıcıları
kullanmaya devam ediyoruz çünkü bize
bilimin sunduğu bir takım olanaklar
son özellikle evrenin oluşumuna ve
maddenin yapısını anlamaya yönelik
çalıştığı için oradan örnek verdim
İçinde bulunduğumuz Yüzyıl'ı birazcık
tanımlamak gerekirse eğer Biz şu anda
endüstri 4-0 kavramını özellikle
2015'ten Sonra işte Yapay zeka gibi
artırılmış gerçeklik gibi büyük veri
gibi nesnelerin interneti gibi Yani
yakında biliyorsunuz 50 milyar makinanın
birbiriyle konuşarak üret yapacağını Biz
biliyoruz Dolayısıyla acaba makineler
bizden daha kıllı Hale mi gelecek
denebilir Japonların öngörüsü toplum 5-0
kavramını yani endüstri 4-0 ile beraber
toplum 5-0 kavramını da toplumu
dönüştürerek eğiterek ve Belki bu
teknoloji ile daha
uyumlu halde yaşayacak hale getirmemiz
gerekiyor gerçekten araştırırken baktım
ki mesela oto o diye bir ne derler
sektör gelişmiş durumda özellikle
pandemi döneminde yaşadık O belki
duymamış olabiliriz ama online tuhaf
Time demekmiş yani sipariş Online Hizmet
offline anlamında Hani bir yemek
siparişi veriyorsunuz Örneğin Fakat
bunun yarattığı sektörü düşündüğünüz
zaman teknolojinin gelişimi ile
sektörlerin sektörlerin gelişimi ile
mesleklerin dönüşümünün farkında olmamız
gerekir özellikle 21 yüzyılın ilk
çeyreğini yaşıyoruz ve Sizler meslek
hayatı olarak yani gençleri bahsediyorum
Önümüzdeki 40-50 yılda bu teknolojinin
sunduğu yani yüzyılımızın sunduğu tüm
yenilikleri tüm dönüşümleri
yaşayacağınız için bir yerde hazır
olmamız gerekiyor konu teknolojiden
açılmışken Tabii ki teknolojinin Hangi
kısmıyla uğraşalım ne üretelim yani
pirinç üretim cep telefonu üreteyim
Yoksa uydu mu üreteyim Ondan sonra yoksa
Süper Lig'den hızlandırıcı mı üreteyim
denebilir ülke olarak gerçekten refahı
yakalamak Daha aydınlık bir geleceğe
doğru emin adımlarla yürümek Esasen
Teknolojinin nimetlerinden teknolojinin
gücünden bilginin gücünden yararlanmayla
ilgili bir şey bilgi demişken diyorlar
ki 21 yüzyıl Bilgi çağı bilgi Çağım
olacak
şöyle bir gerçek var yani ben 14 milyar
yıldan ya da son 14000 yıldan bahsettim
ama insanoğlunun kaydı aldığı günümüzde
Şöyle bir gerçek var üretilen bilg yani
bilginin üretimi işlenmesi dağıtılması
iletilmesi saklanması her ne dersek
aşağı yukarı yılda ikiye katlanır hale
geldi bunu Bazen 300 SEL yasa diye de
anlatıyorlar Dolayısıyla hesaplamada
kuantum bilgisayarları iletmede yeni
interneti saklamada Bulut sistemlerini
bekliyoruz
Önümüzdeki 10-15 yıl içerisinde bunların
çok geliştiğini göreceğiz Örneğin ne tür
bir bilgi paylaşımınız var ne yoğunlukta
dediğimiz zaman internette 60 saniyede
Örneğin YouTube'a 500 saatlik içerik
yükleniyor 200.000 tweet atılıyor 70
milyon mesaj gönderiliyor bu bilginin
kontrolü bu bilginin saklanması
gerçekten
yüzyılımızın en önemli konularından bir
tanesi Peki nasıl bir 21 yüzyıl
dediğimiz zaman yani yolculuğun Hani
yolculuğumuzun 21 yüzyıl ayağını
konuşmuş olalım Yolumuz çok uzundu
biliyorsunuz Bu yüzyılda bu yolculuğun
bulgularına Biz neler ekleyebiliriz
Esasen O sorunun cevabını aramış
oluyoruz 21 yüzyılda baktığımız zaman
entüdyoya sıfır ve toplum 5-0'dan
bahsetmiştim Ama gerçekten özellikle
2050'den sonra uzayda yaşamı aramaya
başlayacağız hani uzay madenciliği gibi
işte ışınlanma gibi kuantum
bilgisayarlarından bahsettim mesela
diyorlar ki 2070'ler gibi Mars'a asansör
olacak şimdi bu fitte çekim dalgalarını
kılavuzluk yapması Mars'a asansör olması
inanılmaz geliyor belki ama yüzyılımız
bitmeden bunun gerçekleşeceğini
öngörebiliyoruz süper uçaklar otonom
araçlar gibi sürücüsüz araçlar gibi
zaten duydunuz ama 21 yüzyıl deyince
Belki de hepsini bir arada yaşayacağımız
yani Bilgi çağı mı denedik çağımı
çekirdek çağı mı yoksa uzay çağı mı
olacak dediğimiz zaman öyle görünüyor ki
değişik basamaklarında yani 2020'ler
2060'lar 2080'ler diye dilimleyecek
olursak bu 400 yılı 400 yılı bir arada
yaşamış olacağız
gerçekten Muhtemelen 20 yüzyılın atom
Yüzyıl olması gibi 21 yüzyılda
çekirdeğin içinden çıkacağı için
teknoloji olarak çekirdek Yüzyıl olarak
anılabilir Peki biz bu yolculukta
aklımızda Neyi tutalım Holding'in bir
deyimine başla değinmiştim hatırlarsanız
diyor ki ustaya yayılmadığımız sürece
insan ırkının Önümüzdeki bin yıllarda
hayatta kalabileceğini sanmıyorum
iyimser bir insanım gezegenlere
yolculuğu Yıldızlara ulaşacağımıza
inanıyorum diyor
Gerçekten biz bu yolun uzunluğunu
zorluğunun farkındayız hızlansak da
belki sınırlara ulaşamayacağız Ama
şimdiki nesil olarak gelecek nesillerin
önünü açık tutmalıyız geleceğe yürürken
ve bilinmeyen ararken o dönemde
Atatürk'ün Hayatta en hakiki mürşit
ilimdir fendir en hakiki rehber ilimdir
fendir sözüne unutmamamız gerekir
bilimin ışığında bilimin aydınlığında
Yolumuz açık geleceğimiz parlak olsun
teşekkür ederim
[Alkış]